welcome to the Permian period
this epic started 300 million years ago
back then our planet had one
supercontinent Pangea surrounded by a
world ocean called pantherlassa then
during early Permian days Earth warmed
to a lush environment with a diversity
of plants and a rapid evolution of
insect and animal life over the next 50
million years Earth kept growing hotter
and drier here in the Permian period
some of the most incredible species that
roamed our young Planet are about to
emerge
there was likely less oxygen in the air
than there is now but you still might be
able to Breathe by the end of the early
Permian the Ice Age was on its way out
and Pangea was becoming a lush world